bonjour à tous je suis c'est 'qui le
texte est qu aujourd'hui nous allons
parler de la création de l'argent alors
comment l'argent et tu crées il existe
plusieurs manières de créer de l'argent
il y as l'impression de billets et le
fera pages de pièces qui représente
seulement 5% de la totalité de l'argent
sur terre c'est la monnaie fiduciaire
qui est basé sur la valeur que lui donne
le pays qui la fabrique et puis il y à
la création monétaire par le crédit avec
ou sans taux d'intérêt qui représentent
95% de l'argent sur terre cet argent
n'existe que sous la forme d'écriture
informatique on appelle cela l'argent
crypte ural c'est quoi l'argent
scripturale et bien c'est très simple
par exemple lorsque vous payez votre
chariot de courses pour 100 euros avec
votre carte bancaire votre compte en
banque sera débité de son euro alors que
le compte du magasin sera crédité de 100
euros pourtant il n'y a eu aucun échange
de billets ni de pièces on parle donc d'
échange d'argent scripturale et
commentcamarche la création monétaire
par le crédit on pense en général est
que les banques ne prêtent que l'argent
qu'elles ont en réserve eh bien non les
banques peuvent prêter plus d'argent
qu'elle n'en possèdent elles créent donc
de l'argent en accordant un crédit à un
état à une entreprise ou à une personne
sous forme d'écriture informatiques en
europe les banques doivent seulement
posséder 8 % des sommes qu'elles prêtent
et c'est ce que l'on appelle les taux de
réserve pour un crédit de 1000 euros la
banque inscrire 1000 euros sur le coup
alors qu'il ne possède que 80 euros elle
vient de créer 920 euros la totalité de
l'argent dans le monde vient donc
d'augmenter de 920 euros et la création
monétaire par le crédit avec tout
intérêt et c'est presque la même chose
la banque inscrire 1000 euros sur le
compte de monsieur grondin mais en
contrepartie elle demande une
rémunération qui représente un
pourcentage de la somme prêtée c'est ce
pourcentage que l'on appelle le taux
d'intérêt en résumé si monsieur grondin
empreinte 1000 euros à la banque qu'il
doit rembourser en en nous et que le
taux d'intérêt est de 5% il devra
rembourser 1000 euros + 5 % c'est-à-dire
1050 euros et que devient cet argent que
monsieur grondin a emprunté les cieux
grand bain va par exemple acheter une
télévision dans un magasin le magasin
rémunère ses employés ses employés
reçoivent leur salaire qu'ils vont à
leur tour dépensés dont d'autres
entreprises qui rémunère d'autres
salariés l'argent circule et permet donc
de faire fonctionner l'économie et
lorsque le crédit est remboursé à la
banque eh bien lorsque monsieur grondin
remboursera à son crédit cet argent
virtuel
disparaîtra jusqu'à ce qu'une nouvelle
personne ou une entreprise propres un
taux de l'argent et ainsi de suite
j'espère que vous avez bien compris ce
qu'est la création de l'argent à bientôt
pour un nouvel épisode